gail becker founded caulipower in 2016
igniting a cauliflower crust pizza craze
and
her company's now valued at more than
500 million dollars which is no joke at
57 years old she has a majority stake in
the company and she's worth 245 million
dollars which means she made the
annual lists of americans which is
healthy women for the first time this
year which was a very big deal we very
rarely have food entrepreneurs making
this list
because you can only really eat so much
people are devouring
power breasts
her kids have celiac disease and she was
making them pizza crust gail becker
found a recipe on pinterest for a simple
cauliflower pizza crust her kids loved
it so much that she figured she might as
well try to make them
for others as well she's the first
generation american and she's born to
holocaust survivors and she really does
credit that was a lot of her
entrepreneurial grit and her drive in
five very short years gail becker has
completely taken over the frozen pizza
crust aisle
and it's really because
her products are simple they have some
little ingredient decks and she was able
to make them and manufacture them in a
way they got them to people quickly
when they really needed them most
she
started out at age 52 in los angeles and
invested
her life savings in doing her first
manufacturing runs and finding a
contract manufacturer to help her get
her product from you know kitchen recipe
to you know full-scale commercial brand
that's playing at walmart and whole
foods in her first year she raised money
from boulder food group because she
really just needed
a significant amount of capital to make
more pizza crusts and get her order
sizes bigger and get more out the door
to again
whole foods and the like kroger target
um
power now has more than fifty percent of
the
gluten-free pizza crust category which
is huge so becker is
a wealthy lady now thanks to this
cauliopower
brand but it's really driven by the
craze towards healthy eating and more
natural ingredients more whole
ingredients less processing and well
obviously this is cauliflower
flour that's processed and you know
formed and shaped into a pizza crust at
the end of the day it is still a far
cleaner ingredient deck and a far more
natural ingredient deck than a lot of
the other mainstream pizza crust brands
out there and that's really how gail
becker and collie power have
found their edge and found their niche
in more than 25 000 stores healthy food
is here to stay i think
even just the pandemic has really made a
lot of people think differently about
how
they're supporting their health and
their body functionality and
the very simple way to do that on a
basic level um is by what you eat and
what you're putting into your mouth and
so you know the cauliflower pizza crust
craze this is by no means limited to
cauli power and gail becker there's a
lot of other competitors that have been
seeing her success and copying and
creating similar products but it really
is a testament to how popular healthy
food has become and how popular less
processed
more natural ingredients have become and
this is a company that will be the
future of natural foods moving forward
[Music]